so you guys are resulta experts or where
the Zelda experts or we consider
ourselves the Zelda experts I don't know
I wanted to hammer out a couple theories
bounce some stuff off you guys um a lot
of people are talking about this and
maybe we could clear some things up or
maybe sort of fuel the hype train I
guess um I really want to know who link
is like who do you guys think link is is
he one we've seen before is he a new guy
he has to be a new so I preface in all
of this with a grain of salt then there
is a time there's an official time line
for Zelda in that like even in the
office some people didn't believe this
whenever like no no there'll historian
they ruled this is where all of these
take place and how old this panned out I
would still take that with a grain of
salt bit I don't think anybody actually
cared over there all of this was after
the fact most of it was retconned n
especially at the beginning like there
was no way that they thought like let's
have a very clear delineation like in in
the beginning they just made Zelda games
and then they made a new Zelda game with
new abilities and I think now they think
about that a little bit more and where
that fits in the timeline but just the
fact that you have three separate
timelines means that somebody who had no
idea what they were doing at some point
sweet now that you've rain on our parade
Alexa to answer your question he's like
Batman right there's there's different
in Robin there's different incarnations
of him it's like this thing that you
passed down yeah he's like a descendant
every time and then it's always he's a
descendant of link and then zelda is a
descendant of that zelda and so on
ganon's knew but link link again is
returning guy yes I stand corrected um
so link though the fact that he's been
asleep for a hundred years usually he's
just this dude that's been living in
like you know the Kokiri woods or
somewhere on windfall island that earth
well that was a dream but turns out like
you know it's usually just a new person
that is selected by the gods or by the
Triforce to be the hero whereas now it's
like they're leaning towards maybe this
is an existing link that's just been
asleep for a long time
well we also don't know that he's been
asleep for a hundred years like calamity
calamity Ganon which is like the most
Genova thing I've ever heard
appears a hundred years before link gets
woken up so he could in theory be asleep
for more than
years so he could also be a just a dude
who's been asleep for a hundred years
they don't but why they don't tell him
he's the hero when he wakes up right did
um you didn't know he was the hero
before I don't think um the the the
mysterious female voice that awakens him
says you are the light our light that
must shine and Hyrule once again so
they're sort of the wordplay they're
kind of implies that he is fear of time
hero of legend some way connected but
she says once again which makes me lean
towards for taking it very literally
okay maybe since he's been asleep he's a
previous link that's been put in stasis
because maybe they don't trust the
reincarnation cycle anymore so he's
woken up to do it again but then there's
the question of who put it like who put
him to sleep who built the hyperbolic
time chamber or whatever the heck he's
in and like stuck him in goo and then
like who woke him up cuz he's alone um I
don't know if there's a lot of
Goodyear's seems so little amount of
time for for the way that the world has
become like you imagine the change that
goes through any place in a hundred
years and even if this is one of the
more recent game or one of the the
bigger games that came out recently like
it seems like the world to to have
gotten to this level of wildness and
disrepair would have had to have been
500 years or some longer amount of time
I think it'd be longer than 500 years
because winwaker if we're looking at the
whole idea that it's the post winwaker
timeline because there's the core ox in
the rock salt' winwaker is a thousand
years after ocarina and then every so
this would if the seed rained maybe it'd
be like another thousand years two
thousand years you say what's the
closest after ocarina majora in terms of
time majora i mean it's different
timeline so it's hard to quantify but
yeah majora is like immediately after
when he's like child and go searching
for navi right because yeah like so iced
i need to correct myself from earlier
the Phantom Hourglass spirit tracks link
are the same link correct yeah and
winwaker yeah that's the same link
throughout that like the same body link
yeah tune like is there's not more than
one tomb link I mean unless you count
like the tune looking links from Four
Swords wherever but is when weaker link
the same as the Gameboy link or the game
3ds link well I thought I was between
worlds yeah well when you go to Wind
Waker and then Phantom Hourglass
slash spirit tracks I thought that was a
different link
for those individuals it's the same for
Phantom Hourglass in spirit tracks sure
that was my initial inclination but yeah
so I'm wondering because like my initial
thing during my demo that I played the
one hand I saw was that that old man you
come across said you'll drown like
Hyrule did which Wind Waker itself is
like the Great Flood happened and then
winwaker itself you're pretty much the
islands are just the highest point of
the Hyrule which is all underwater so
that's why I was thinking was in that
timeline sometime at least after
winwaker or maybe spare tracks or
Phantom Hourglass not necessarily in
that order but I mean there's a huge gap
in between Phantom Hourglass and spirit
tracks so maybe I was like oh maybe
that's one that I mean according the
timeline the pirate story the new
continent was discovered but this also
still looks like the Hyrule we used to
know because there's I mean certain
landmarks indicated that it seemed the
important landmarks not even just like
things that you might be able to think
is one thing or another but that that is
definitely the temple of time that it's
definitely Death Mountain in the
background that's definitely the
elvadine bridge
yeah sure or the bridge of hylia they
both kind of look the same all the
architecture in Twilight Princess kind
of looked like that though so um yeah
how about that let's talk about the
temple of time for a second the temple
of time and then all that technology
like all the guardians and stuff I can't
think of any other place in in the Zelda
timeline that we saw technology that
looked like that with the same aesthetic
other than the Tower of the gods and
winwaker that one boss with the hands I
feel like that not directly but that
seems to be in some ways an aesthetic
that I feel like permeates all of this
Elder games especially the ones from the
NES and like of course the graphics
don't quite show that the same way but
when you when you think about like the
original NES game and you're walking
around you touch a statue and it comes
to life like to me that was the games
now are kind of a representation of that
similar technology and that similar
ideal to me is like even as a child that
was never magic that was like some
technology that's bringing those things
to life and and I think the especially
the callbacks that we see in breath of
the wild are almost a reimagining of the
original Zelda
from from that kind of ideal from that
kind of design perspective so what
you're saying is actually that breath is
wild is a totally new time line means
that another prevailing theory no the
prevailing theories are people seem to
think it's either directly after zelda
two or it's the failure timelines yeah
there's evidence that it's at the end of
the failure timeline and the the child
hero timeline which is Majora's Mask
that's the when he goes stays a child so
actually talked about it yet to preface
this for people who aren't familiar with
how the timeline works the quantum
physics oh yeah it might be worth
clarifying that something yeah anybody
besides us TL DR after ocarina of time
the timeline of zelda splits because of
all their screwing around with time
splits into three different possible
outcomes and one is the fallen hero
timeline which is link fails to defeat
Ganon hi-oh goes into decline and the
first game after that that is linked to
the past
followed by Oracle of Ages and seasons
Link's Awakening link between worlds
Triforce here Legend of Zelda and legend
Delta to the adventure link and there's
a lot of evidence for breadth of the
while being after Zelda 2 but we'll get
to that the child hero timeline link
successfully defeats Ganon Zelda sends
him back in time to be a child again and
he remains a child that kicks off
Majora's Mask and then Twilight Princess
and Four Swords Adventures okay I feel
like fits nowhere which is probably my
favorite timeline yeah you learned that
time like that's your timeline Mikey's
the child here and there's the adult
hero timeline which is winwaker Phantom
Hourglass bear tracks all of the
evidence for this being after zelda 2 is
because of how just awful everything
looks like everything is in is in total
decline everything looks really gross
the Hyrule is gone Hyrule is completely
gone and everything is in ruin and that
wouldn't necessarily be true in the
Majora's Mask timeline because Hyrule
still exists in some way but like at the
end of zelda ii i think it's like the
world is overgrown they talk about it
being just like in total ruin and then i
think the name breath of the wild kind
of kind of insinuates that like oh like
we've returned back to
like the wild state like if it's a game
about link like rediscovering Hyrule and
like recolonizing or repopulate reap
rediscovering the entire map of the
world then I mean that might be it in
gameplay why is it it almost fits that
the best because this I think more than
any other Zelda game calls back to the
original adventure both in the sense of
discovery that you're going out in the
world and it doesn't matter what order
you go through the dungeons and you can
do it in any order like it's really
rediscovering that aspect of the Legend
of Zelda mythos and gameplay yeah link
between worlds was probably the closest
we've been before this to that and
that's the game before Legend of Zelda
in the timeline yes it is which that
would put yeah that kind of game place
makes sense cuz yeah all the timelines
the gameplay does kind of a line I mean
obviously Phantom Hourglass appear
tracks because the dsr pretty similar
that was like that pointing with a
stylus and attacking with a stylus and
blowing into it and whatnot but the
actual like you just had the gameplay of
a failure time light is all kind of not
all of them but there's a lot more
exploration in those I feel like as
opposed to the other ones which are like
you know that open linear kind of style
which is prevalent is Zelda series
especially since what 1986 when the
first game came out yeah um the failure
timeline also especially with Majora's
Mask still deals with the meddling in
time that was done in Ocarina and in in
some of the footage we've seen abreast
of the wild their ears there's a statue
of Helia
Helia is only mentioned in Skyward Sword
and never again um the only other
goddess who really hear about that's not
the three goddesses is the goddess of
time that like Zelda and others talked
about in Ocarina of Time and Zelda as we
learned in Skyward Sword her she is the
fit the human and carnate of hylia so
it's kind of safe to assume that like
maybe all of her incarnations are also
reincarnated Helia and actually is being
mentioned again and if maybe he'll eeeh
and thus goddess of time are like the
same or their powers are the same maybe
we'll see some of that breath of the
wild some of that timeline manipulation
in breath of the wild I know people are
saying based on footage they've seen
they think maybe there will be some
playing with Hyrule when it was thriving
and then this decrepit Hyrule that we're
sort of running around in although I
can't imagine a map that big running
through two different versions of that
world
like that's insanity no so I don't know
I don't think that'll happen but yeah
because you hear about din they ruin
fourth for how many games in this series
I'd probably like half they talk about
them a lot and they're in Skyward Sword
right yeah and they're they like
disciples of high Lea or daughters
they're I think they're like they're
part of the pantheon yes I'm try to the
Pantheon but you have to collect
remember you have to get like dense fire
and you have to get all the silly songs
for Phi to dance to isn't another thing
about breath of the wild that maybe this
is a convergence yeah people are saying
that there's so much evidence of it
being like we have the bridges from the
bridges from Twilight Princess wolf link
the technology like the sheikah presence
which is more prevalent in the fallen I
think the fallen hero timeline the
fallen hero timeline has all the sheikah
in it link to the past through Delta to
Zelda 2 has Impa watching over sleeping
Zelda like maybe that voice that wakes
you up in the beginning isn't zelda
maybe it's info like calling you to
action but that's where the sheik is
most prevalent but then you have the
elements of majora's mask of the core ox
and the rock salts that you find salt
the crystallized salt from the ancient
sea I think as the description which
brings you into that timeline so this
could be I mean it's a good opportunity
I feel like Nintendo has really sort of
flung these games all out there and like
you said they sort of wrecked conned and
retro actively fit everything into the
timeline so this might be a way for them
to be like we're done with that here we
are
and just converging it I don't know what
do you think or even the timeline is
kind of new I remember up until a few
years ago like that was just a source of
incredible conjecture that everybody
tried to fit the games into a single
timeline which is impossible so the
prevailing theory was that there were
two timelines and then when they came
out with this that there are three
timelines like I think that was beyond
imagining that they would do something
kind of that crazy but fracked like that
is a fractured timeline at that point
and if you do something that that
repairs it that would seem to kind of
bring that mythos bring that story back
together I could see that making sense
so I think my initial response was that
it's the Wind Waker timeline it's the
you know that Gannon's defeated time no
no sorry the adult timeline
funny because it always screw of me
because it's Toon Link but it's the
adult timeline Toon Link and this is
kind of animation it's like a
combination of toilet like Wind Waker
and Skyward Sword art styles almost but
it's my crazy crackpot theory is that so
calamity again and why I changed his
name to that it's either it's either
always been Ganondorf
I mean Ganondorf is just a version right
but calamity itself almost leads me to
leave what if I hear me out what if
Ganon found an advantage in somehow like
he found how to manipulate time and he
found out that if he maybe he knew about
these two other versions of himself that
were fighting so maybe he thought he'd
become more powerful if he let the
timelines converge and then that's why
we're seeing like traces of each
timeline in it so that calamity itself
was like the convergence of these like
streams of time I don't know if that's
the crackpot theory but that'd be pretty
cool if he's like oh [ __ ] if I unite all
these and bring all these different
quantum like parallel universes together
I would have an advantage over link
maybe that's why link was called back
finally because he's like what if like
that link is a combination of a flake
spirit tracks link for swords venture
link an adventure of link the map is so
large that they could really bring these
together that you could go to a part of
the map where you see train tracks laid
out then the part that we're in right
now UKIP's or the part that we got to
play you're finding salt from the
ancient sea that if you get to find all
these elements from previous games it
would both be really fun for us from a
nostalgia perspective yeah but also
really interesting for story wise just
also sort of makes sense to me I mean I
don't remember the last time this much
was riding on a Zelda game maybe because
maybe it's just because it's I mean
Twilight Princess you could say the same
thing for the it was like a selling
point for the Wii but this more than
ever I mean Nintendo was not as in was
not in the same shape when the we came
out they weren't like wow they were
pretty well off from what if I mean
memory serves not have been great but
when the first Zelda came out for Wii
that was that was it was unproven at
that point here was a game for a new
system that from a hardcore gamer
perspective seemed ridiculous the here's
this motion controller thing I just want
to game with the controller and this was
for me this is a selling point for so
many people like well this is where I'm
gonna get the first way to play Zelda I
will
and the weeds superseded any popularity
that it had with gamers mm-hmm but then
now going onto the Wii U which has been
fine a failure in so many perspectives
this will be a selling game for the NX
there were there are so many people I
even like among my friends who are like
I wanted to buy a Wii U I've been
waiting for Zelda now I'll just wait for
the NX because Zelda will be on that
this is a game that has so much power
for so many people yeah there's
definitely a lot riding on it which i
think is why people are sort of at least
people like us are like bending over
backwards trying to figure out like how
the game fits and like what's in it and
what it's doing it's just like it we
know it's unimportant it's silly but
it's it's so much fun to yes think of
it's fun but like if they hadn't
published an official one in the
hireling story I might not be doing it
as much but like it's crazy like
thinking back like the fact that quantum
physics came into play with a Zelda
timeline with branching parallel
universes is nuts and that's why it's
cool
but it's also why not why not just
embrace that at this point why not like
actually time has been one of the
biggest mechanics throughout Zelda like
through all the games like Majora's Mask
you use it as a like a mechanic in the
game ocarina of time that's what started
this whole this whole like branching
universes why Chuck infinite on it yeah
yeah why not do that that'd be awesome
I mean you woke up near the temple of
time like that's where the game starts
you come out of the cave and the temple
of time is like right there there has to
be something significant about the fact
that it's one of the first buildings you
see I have a but no I was saying that
that was another like thing that I'd saw
right away cuz I the demo I played I
think we play the same demo you start
wherever and then you but if you respawn
you go back to your where you woke up
initially but we were we already been
equipped with like the blue tunic and
pretty decent weapons and whatnot but
then you see the temple of time right
there we were wondering I didn't go
inside it but I wanted to but I'm
looking forward to seeing if you can
gather story elements just by exploring
the world you can but I'm wondering how
much Nintendo's gonna how much emphasis
Newton's gonna place on that well
they're not showing like villages and
people yet because they said it would be
such a huge story spoilers so I know
that we were on the old man called it
the great plateau which is fallen
Skyloft
like that's where I was founded like
that's where it happened and there's
just no one there which was sort of
weird and I wonder if they just pulled
all those elements out for the demo so
wouldn't give anything away because it
seemed really just open and like but
cobble and infested and that was it they
didn't mention that for the demo is also
more densely packed than the full game
would be that because this was a very
short a relatively short experience that
we got to spend with the game they put
more per square foot then you'll
probably find in the actual game so he
came III not to bring up not to bring up
sad interviews but remember onuma said
that like he tried to explain the reason
why there can't be a female link is
because like what would Zelda do I
wonder if that was his answer because he
couldn't say anything for story reasons
like that's kind of why I feel that
maybe the link that we're seeing is a
link from another game which would mean
he would have to be male because all the
other links were male I don't know that
might have been I just I just feel like
that that comment was so like
ill-thought-out like maybe like he
panicked a little and was like well I
can't say it's because of the story
because then everyone will immediately
start thinking it but like my theory is
that this is another link and that
statement kind of tilts towards it yeah
that this is going to directly connect
to the game we're going to meet this
link do you think they'll have the same
Zelda though or will it be a new Zelda
the embodied like a spirit Zelda will it
be someone who's also been asleep for a
hundred years and another little Sheik
well the only other other character that
we've seen lasts that long or sleep or
whatever is info right like in Skyward
Sword we had old inviting young info imp
is always the person who's there like
watching a result of like I think that
maybe that voice waking him up is Impa
yeah she's weren't called to action
she's like the bed protecting the royal
family for how long yeah I don't know
how long but from a gameplay perspective
here's something I have because this
game doesn't come out for another nine
months or so with an ax which is you
know like supposedly gonna be more
powerful which I'm assuming would be
more powerful how much more powerful no
one knows and the Wii U only twenty
teraflops probably yeah that's a kid
that's what I was thinking what if this
is like you said he mentioned the great
plateau which he has fallen Scylla
what if you actually you could fast
travel right now which we all fast
travel I think in the demo what if you
get loft wings to travel around the
world in I couldn't be I was just a
horse but we saw a thing floating like
it looked like it could have been like a
bird with outstretched wings or like a
floating island or something I don't
know what do you think that thing is
that I think that had to be an island I
think it was just so far off in the
distance that there is some other
floating place so how do you get there
you'll probably either teleport little
thing I don't know because you can hunt
animals so the amount of people working
on this game and like the amount you can
already do this is just a theory I don't
I don't know if it'll actually pan out
but what if you could like tame wild
horses right is that something you do
yeah you're riding a horse okay so maybe
you can find loft wings and then tame
them and fly around with those because
you have a you have a parachute you
could just jump off them at any time in
flowtown I think that'd be awesome
what if they let you breed laughing's
like you breed chocobos in Final Fantasy
7 that'd be sick it would also tied the
washing thing would also tie into like
you know maybe they mentioned highly a
lot they meant or they mentioned Helia
however you want to pronounce it they
mentioned you know the great plan said
loft wing yeah there you got the goddess
and the laughing's confused that's why
it's very confusing to me because when I
say highly I read that as loftwing in my
can't if I'm just if I just hear
somebody say it I don't know which one's
win that's the source of your confusion
I don't know I think it'd be cool be
able to fly around this world it's huge
yeah they have to there has to be some
kind of alternate transportation that's
not fast travel for a world that big
like for people that just want to like
fly across it or run across it or
whatever well there's probably a flute
of some kind right that you'll toot and
a bird will come and pick you up
but the tutor flute or maybe it'll call
back to the whirlwind or that would just
come pick you up yeah or maybe they're
just ignoring that because there is fast
travel and I mean that kind of element
wouldn't exist anymore
Amy mmm world seems awful big where do
you guys think of the old man like who
do you think he is that seems to be
another sticking point for people
because people are like oh he looks like
every old man from every Zelda game but
a lot of people say that he specifically
looks like a much agen virgin must
much the much aged version of the king
of Hyrule as shown in I will maker the
the obvious first impression that you
get is both from the gameplay
perspective and that you're meeting an
old man who's giving you advice is that
first Elda game and you think the old
dude in the cave it's like here's your
sword go out and do stuff but I don't
think they're gonna make it that simple
I do think there has to be some other
answer there has to be something deeper
than that I have a theory my theory is
that the old man you were talking about
calamity Ganon earlier and about Ganon
converging the timeline because working
with all of his selves could probably
make him more powerful we know that when
we wake when link wakes up in the game
he is he's woken up and I think the old
man tells him like Oh like he's very
close to breaking out like at some point
Ganon in the game I bet breaks the seal
and comes out but what is keeping him
back maybe it's because he's not
completely whole I have a theory that
the old man is actually Ganon or a piece
of Ganon because Ganon has a great track
record of not doing anything by himself
and getting others to do his dirty work
you have him following link around and
winwaker you have in Twilight Princess
he basically makes Zant clean up
everything and then he steps in and sort
of takes over so maybe maybe that's him
like and all the demo footage we've seen
link collects a spirit orb and then
Ganon like parachutes in and it's like
oh hey man I see you've got another
spirit or pass it going you good like I
nobody has that much interest in anybody
else unless it's for their own personal
interests so I think that's a piece of
Ganon and Gaiman also has a proclivity
for not learning from those mistakes oh
yeah going oh you know I should probably
involve the one person who always
murders me know into this plan if
someone was going to include someone
who's going to murder them into a plan
it would begin yeah no I think I think
it I think it could begin and I think it
might also sort of riff a little bit on
like what Mike said like he's not
complete until he gathers all pieces of
himself and that's why he's hibernating
all the Horcrux all the Horcruxes of
Ganon will be collected and what you're
actually doing when you collect spirit
orb does you're collecting Ganon
Horcruxes
I stared Lion King I think it will end
up being the king of Hyrule just like an
exile this hermit with his baked apples
some kind or like the the ancestor of
the king who's just been watching over
and he's here to help Shepherd the
kingdom into a new era of light like the
king of Hyrule is like Impa watch zelda
maybe Impa somewhere watching zelda and
the king of hyrule lives outside that
cave waiting for link to rewrite maybe
yeah tipped him off or something hey
he's gonna come out yo he's coming back
can you get over there can you pick him
up he's been hitting snooze for like a
hundred years 300 years now but he just
waken the F up and coming out during my
demo I just kind of ignored him and I
went down this hill and I saw some trees
and I just started attacking the trees
there was stuff to light on fires why
would you do that so that's another
thing coming
Zelda trope is the Master Sword didn't
see it in the demo obviously but it's
usually a big thing it's like going to
the Lost Woods you'll find it there I
pull it on the pedestal here King Arthur
but in this one I think it'd be awesome
cuz you can have so many different
weapons but I'm assuming you'll
eventually come across it it'll be do
they show it in the trailer or whatever
they showed they showed it stuck in the
pedestal the same way you see it and
like Twilight Princess in other games
but did anyone else it's also in the
logo but if you notice that it looks
like [ __ ] like I'm glad that costing
masters like it's been at the bottom of
an ocean it's been yeah if it's that
time line or whatever but I like I kind
of sick of just it's always in this like
serene grotto I want it to be kind of
like this thing that people have
forgotten about like people forgot about
link kind of except for like you know
Empire whoever but I want them him just
I want it to be just this unassuming
thing you stumble across and then you're
like oh my god like it'll be on Reddit
within a day after the game releasing
but right I almost hope they don't make
it the story thing that you have to do I
hope you just come across in because
that'll end so much more to like the
whole Forgotten realm kind of idea am I
remembering wrong that in a Link to the
Past even though it is in kind of a
secluded grotto the sword itself was
kind of crappy and mangled looking and
as you're walking around the Lost Woods
when you first go get the sword there
are all these other swords sticking out
and they look clean and ready to go and
you're like oh no this is a crappy one
this isn't the real one and you see this
one kind of really old looking one of
course it's set into a stone and it
looks
very important but it's otherwise a
decrepit looking sword then as you pull
it out becomes imbued with power and
becomes cool-looking again
oh yeah cuz toilet princess it was also
in a grotto when you finally get it by
like ocarina of time it was in the
temple of time it was just pretty much
like it was super serene or pristine
someone's sitting there polishing it
every year I would love it if like you
had to like swim to the bottom of like a
pond and like pull the sword out of like
cannons like decrepit like rock body if
that's where it was located this is the
Wind Waker timeline like you say and the
sword the last time we saw it was the
bottom of the ocean
stuck in Gannet Ganon turned into a rock
who retrieved it and put it in the
serene little grotto like did someone
get it like we don't know the only other
person who can handle it is Zelda so do
you think maybe like Zelda came and got
it and like put it somewhere else
yeah like what's she been up to would
she do that she got bored maybe just
finds its own way there it's like if I
came back to life and flew back or she
knew is important is like the god killer
or whatever there's a 10% chance I will
be needed again in the future yeah I'm
out of here
yeah no um what about this speaking of
Phi Skyward Sword another element that
we saw there that we haven't seen
anywhere else except kind of in this
game is all that technology like all
those robots and stuff and here we have
chica we have the she could iPad and we
have the guardians and we have just all
of these like technologically r Lee
there's remnants of like an advanced
technological civilization in this area
like what do we think about that do we
does that like new do you think maybe
like if the ocean drained that's where
it like it came from like that sort of
mystifies me like what do you think of
that I think I think it's always been
there but like I mentioned before I
think that permeates the Zelda timeline
that it was the strongest in the
beginning because it came from this much
more advanced simulate civilization and
that most of that technology most of
that knowledge was lost but you have
pieces of it all the time from Majora's
Mask and Ocarina of times as chica
stones that have some weird
from our perspective almost a mystical
property but from from a much more
important civilization they probably
have a more scientific like there's a
reason that they react and they they are
able to do the things they do
um and the original Zelda itself when
you touch creatures and they come to
life like I don't think of that as a
mystical thing I think of them as the
same robots as Skyward Sword like that
is the representation of that just on a
crappier visual level
well even like I always took it once I
played Skyward Sword that any subsequent
magic was kind of a result of that
civilization that they found some way to
bottle it like the ocarina you can warp
around it's that same blue energy that
sucks you up before it deposits you
outside the shadow temple or the fire
temple Majora's Mask you manipulate you
rewind and fast-forward and slow down
and speed up time I mean what toilet
princess comes along and you can still
warp right correct it seems like now
that you have these remote detonated
bombs that have that blue glowing energy
his arrows themselves look like these
plasma things he clicks that trigger and
they're ready to blow up with the magic
magic arrows wherever they are it seems
like yeah in terms of the attack and the
magic it seems like it's this is the
closest we've gotten to Skyward Sword
and chronologically which would be
interesting because that would lend
credence to like a combined timeline or
like earlier on in the timeline or the
Wind Waker timeline I guess if they're
still talking about like the flood and
how it took over all these the Hylian
technology yeah there's some there's
some evidence that like that breath of
the wild takes place before ocarina of
time or maybe directly after because of
like the hill iya statues and like the
temple of time or like the sheikah stuff
but again like they talk about the flood
and Hyrule sinking and the rock salt so
I feel like no matter what the answer is
I think everything more strongly points
to this being in the would maker
timeline or it's cool gameplay stuff
they just came with it and now they're
gonna let us figure out how it fits in
the time they've tricked us and that's
why we're sitting here on a Tuesday
afternoon banging our heads against the
wall for Zelda theories yeah they're
gonna hire someone to fit this in
somewhere the shared universe is
Tarantino asking that they have back
themselves into the person they're gonna
hire is just read it and I even figure
it out well we'll take the one that
makes the most sense doesn't do that
they're gonna listen to this podcast
we're doing their work for them yeah so
if you're listening yeah is there
anything else that we wanted to discuss
cuz that's like all of it
yeah think we've gotten through all the
theories did anybody notice at the
reveal trailer music is sort of a riff
on the Ocarina of Time menu music do you
do it's the same it's no it's the same
melody pulled apart with the notes the
same notes occurring in the same order
with a different different length of
each note so I did have one other theory
and this wasn't mine this was when I ran
all frame Z or is and a lot of the the
Zelda games there's a representation of
the console that you're playing on like
whether it's the Nintendo 64 controller
the Wii U gamepad in this case one of
the first technological things you get
is that sheikah tablet of the NX
controller in some way if that's how
this is gonna work or how they envision
the NX controller working as a it's
literally just like I'd like a like a
like a Palm Pilot so yeah a little what
if that's what the NX itself is or maybe
just the NX controller but I think it
would make a lot of sense for them to
have some kind of carryover some kind of
crossover with what you're actually
holding in your hand when you play this
game
yeah because heavy yeah what if you're
playing on a screen it's like the second
screen experience you can travel and
then play like a 3ds I mean that was
like I thought prevalent theory earlier
on but this maybe I don't know if it
went credence but it's still it doesn't
like deny the fact that that might be it
and this is a game that they've already
said is going to be playable with the
pro controller you don't have to have a
second screen to play it and also just
the fact after we played breath of the
wild demo that the breath of a while is
just confirmation it's not gonna be
completely far-fetched what a Nintendo
does the NX cuz this is like still feels
like a console experience it's something
we you it has to work for both of them
it has to like you said the pro
controller it's not gonna be this weird
like mobile game which is reassuring in
a lot of ways yeah I know there's been
so much fear and speculation because we
know nothing well that they would just
kind of go with a maybe an underpowered
Android or mobile platform that would be
fine but maybe wouldn't capture that the
same fidelity of gameplay that you would
want out of a console experience
that's interesting Wow mind blown
maybe we're all ready so all this talk
about the NX maybe we've been playing on
the NX the entire time through that demo
kind of not really very possible some
inception kind of stuff is all deception
yeah we did it I feel like I'm more
confused now yeah more confused
so this timeline is obviously still
close to correct that's what they're
doing with that yay here's the news this
is where breath of the wild fits in I
figured it out we did it thanks guys I
appreciate it thanks for having us
thanks Alex
you